AlAlors, les images de M.
GaGauthier, qui arrive avec son
coconvoi de la Côtete-Nord, c'et
dedes images presque en train,
asastronome, on va passer la nut
popour plusieurs des manifestan.
PoPour l'instant, disons-le, il
n'n'y a pas foule, il y a du moe
mamais il n'y a pas de foule, on
veverra. Stéphanie, Michel et
MaMartine, bonsoir. Je vais pasr
àà l l'autre ville tout de suite
rereviendra à Q Québec après.s.,
lala police d'Ottawa disait assz
clclairement : nous, on ne pense
papas que c'est une opération
popolicièrere qui doit résoudre
cecela, c'est un problèmeme
nanational, d'où l'idée de
l'l'armée, voyez ce que M. Trudu
a a répondu.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
prpremier ministre du Canada
- - Il est temps que
leles manifestants rentrent
chchez eux. Nous savons
quque les forces policièreres,
quque ce soit la police d'Ottawa
ouou la GRC qui a des ressources
auaussi, sont là p pour régler
lala situation. Et en tant que
gogouvernement, nous allons être
llà p pour répondre à d des dems
foformelles ou bien de la Ville
d'd'Ottawa ou bien de la provin,
s's'ils ont besoin de plus
dede ressources.
M Mais pour l'instant, c'est ps
ququelque chose qu'on est en trn
dede regarder d'envoyer les fors
ararmées contre des citoyens
cacanadiens.
-Q-Question d'envoyer l'armée.
ToTour de table. Comment voyaita
susuite des choses?
- - Certainement qu'on souhaite
ququ'il y ait une issue pacifiqe
àà t tout ça et qu'on soit pas
obobligé d'amener l'armée dans e
dédécor. Je pense que les
mamanifestations, d'accord que
totout le monde a le droit de
mamanifester ça fait partie de a
dédémocratie, mais assiéger une
viville, c'est une autre histoi.
EtEt tous les gestes qu'on a vus
dedepuis une semaine, c'est quad
mmêmeme inacceptable, donc on ne
pepeut pas laisser 250 personne,
mmêmeme si elles ont des gros
camions, des gros bras, on ne
pepeut pas les laisser prendre n
ototage le Parlement. Il y a 17
mimillions d'électeurs qui ont
vovoté aux élections, il y a pas
sisi longtemps, et qui ont élu .
TrTrudeau. Que ça plaise ou nonà
seses 250 personnes, elles ne ft
papas le poids, elle ne peut pas
ararriver comme ça et demander
totout et rien il est possible,y
cocompris que M. Trudeau s'en
aiaille. C'est plutôt t AU de
papartir.
- - Michel David leparti ne, one
lalance la balle, la police
d'd'Ottawa dit que ça les dépas,
M.M. Trudeau dit qu'il ne va pas
enenvoyer l'armée contre les
CaCanadiens, on ne trouve pas de
reremorqueur qui accepterait
d'd'enlever des collègugues. Onn
vava ou comme ça?
- - D'abord, faudrait avoir un
fofondement légal à u une quelce
exexclusion, on peut demander ue
ininjonction, faut qu'elle soit
babasée sur quelque chose. À
papartir de ce moment, les forcs
dede l'ordre sont mandatées pour
exexécuter la décision d'un
trtribunal. À ce que je sache, n
n'n'est pas rendu encore à c cet
ététat. Je pense que
l'l'incontournable. Les
cacamionneurs, j'ai
l'l'impression... je comprends
ququ'il y a des éléments
exextrémistes qui ont une analye
didifférente de celle du commun
dedes mortels, mais il y avait e
cecertaine sympathie dans la
popopulation au départ d'une
papartie de la population, mais
elelle disparaît t à l la vitese
l'l'éclair, cette sympathie, je
pepense qu'à u un moment donné,
j'j'espèrere qu'ils vont se dir:
cece qu'on avait à d démontrer,
c'c'est fait. On s'en va.
- - Quand on entend  une mèrerei
didit : j'ai pas pu aller au
rerendez-vous, mon fils et, il
avavait jauni. On dit : ça suff.
- - Je pense que le compte à
rerebours est parti. Il va avoir
auaussi l'exemple de ce qui va e
papasser en fin de semaine à
QuQuébec, mais là, , il y a dess
dudu quartier qui commence à
mamanifester, à p pour faire une
mamanifestation contre
mamanifestation. Il y a des gens
ququi sont dans des situations
asassez difficiles, le cas de la
mmèrere qui peut amener son enft
àà l l'hôpipital, on ne peut pas
fafaire autrement que d'êtrtre
sysympathique à c cette situati.
IlIl va commencer à y y en avoir
d'd'autres situations comme ça.
AlAlors, il risque de se retrour
avavec un noyau de plus en plus
pepetit, s'il n'est pas j'ai
l'l'impression comptable fait l-
dedessus. Il va falloir qu'il
fafasse sortir de là..
- - C'est des images des citoyes
ququi vont manifester à l leur r
dedevant les manifestants en
disant : r rentre à l la maison.
Q Québec, avec l'exemple
d'd'Ottawa, et peut-êtrtre qu'on
paparle de Québec, finalement, n
vava dire demain, après-s-demai:
sasavez-vous, il y avait à p peu
prprès s personne. Mais quand m,
onon se prépare. Écoutez toute a
clclasse politique qui dit : n't
papas faire de grabuge chez nou.
- - On tolérera aucun grabuge
enen fin de semaine!
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Le message que le premier
miministre peut envoyer, d'abor,
ilil peut êtrtre clair. Alors, e
mamanifestation pacifique, oui.
JaJammer Québec pedant
dedes semaines, non!
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - Demander la levée des mesurs
sasanitaires, c'est manifester
cocontre la solidarité. Puis le
nonom de notre parti, c'est quo?
C'C'est Québec solidaire.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chchef, Parti québécois
- - Je veux pas non plus qu'on
alalimente la polarisation en
didisant : il y a des mauvaises
mamanifestations. Ça a lieu
cece soir ou demain, là..
BiBien, on demande à c ces gensà
dede se comporter avec civisme.
- - Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois, c'est
ququand mêmeme ironique, Michel,
ququ'il fait un peu  la morale à
d'd'autres manifestants. Il a dà
blbloqué une couple de rues.
- - tout le monde a été surprise
cecette intervention de M. Nadeu
DuDubois. Je ne pense pas que ce
sosoit à l lui ni à q qui que ct
dede décider quelle est la bonne
cacause, quelle mauvaise cause.e
drdroit de manifester est là o u
papas là. . Je pense que c'est s
çaça meilleur, c'est trèss
cecertainement. Maintenant, je
pepense que d'abord, sur le plan
lologistique de l'homme du tiré
dedes leçons de droit, je ne pee
papas qu'on va permettre aux
cacamions de venir lequel la
cocolline parlementaire, on va
esessayer de les garder un peu n
pépériphérie, j'imagine. Et je
pepense... enfin, tout le discos
ququ'on entend dans la populatin
dedepuis quelques jours, le
cacarnaval, les enfants, j'ai
l'l'impression que les
mamanifestants vont se garder ue
pepetite gênene un peu plus à
OtOttawa.
- - J'ai cette profession je me
trtrompe, ce sera pas aussi gros
quque ce qu'on croit, Les messas
onont été entendus, que les gens
nene veulent pas, jour du
cacarnaval, demain, mettre la
viville en étau.
- - L'impression qu'on avait que
c'c'est que les policiers à Q Qc
onont tiré des leçons de ce qu's
onont observé à O Ottawa. Ils ne
sosont pas les camionneurs se
rerendre directement sur le
teterrain de la colline
paparlementaire. Déjà, , devanta
cocolline parlementaire, il y a
dedes barricades, ce qui veut de
quque ils n'ont pas à s stationr
clclairement sur le terrain de a
cocolline parlementaire. Les
dédélégations comparent des vues
etet qu'on confine finalement ls
cacamionneurs seulement sur René
LéLévesque, pour ceux qui
coconnaissent l'endroit. Les
popoliciers sont là, , ils vonte
llà, , et M. Legault, la classe
popolitique au complet va envoyr
unun signal de calme, on n'est s
asassis entre deux chaises comme
d'd'autres politiciens l'ont fat
àà O Ottawa, et non payé cher, a
didit. Mais ici, tout le monde t
ununanime et respecter les règl,
c'c'est pour ça qu'on a un peu
l'l'impression que ça durera pas
lolongtemps, surtout les
rerestaurateurs aussi sortent pr
didire : moi, c'est mon premier
weweek-end, sur la Grande Allée,
j'j'ai plus d'annulation que de
réréservations. Alors, le but de
lala manifestation, c'est ça,
c'c'est la levée des mesures
sasanitaires.
- - Attendons, on ne le sait pa.
- - C'est ça. Je pense que la
sysympathie du public pour ces
gegens s'amenuise énormément, is
ététaient tous pour ce faire
papasser pour des grands martyr,
mamais finalement, il y a des gs
ququi sont pas mal plus malmenés
papar la pandémie, il y a des gs
ququi sont à l l'hôpipital et qe
pepeuvent pas avoir d'opération,
leles travailleurs de la santé,
etetc., donc ces gens n'ont pase
MoMonop Paul du ras-le-bol du...
sisite en serrant les coudes etn
rerespectant les mesures qu'on
pepeut passer  par-dessus la
cicinquièmeme.
- - Encore une fois, le droit de
mamanifester est sacré, mais ily
a a une différence entre
mamanifester et tout bloquait. n
chchange de sujet. La langue, le
gogouvernement de M. Legault
s's'était engagé, avait dit que
c'c'était une priorité de donner
dede l'argent pour agrandir le
cécégep Dawson à M Montréal que
cécégep anglophone qui accueille
auaussi des francophones
évévidemment. Le Parti québécois
totoujours été contre, c'était e
hihistoire qui roulait un peu. ,
M.M. Legault dit : très s bien,n
fifinancera pas le cégep Dawson.
JeJe vous mets en contact. Autre
susujet  linguistique, le minise
JoJolin-Barrette qui ne voulait
papas qu'on impose le bilinguise
chchez les juges, il a perdu une
mamanche hier. Est retrouvée à
l'l'Assemblée nationale dans un
mémélange et une confrontation.
- - Concernant Dawson,
momonsieur le président, la chee
dede l'opposition officielle,
pupuis je suis pas surpris,
nonous ditit que ça serait
prprioritaire pour elle d'agranr
leles cégeps anglophones avant
leles cégeps francophones.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Dawson, c'est son gouvernemt
ququi l'a priorisé, c'est
soson gouvernement qui a voulu
l'l'accélérer dans le projet de
loloi 66 qu'il a mis de l'avant.
MoMonsieur le président, comment
onon appelle un francophone qui
ététudie à D Dawson?
- - 50 % seulement des étudiants
ququi étudient à D Dawson sont
dedes anglophones. Donc, comment
onon appelle des étudiants
ququi Dawson? La moitié,
c'c'est pas des anglophones.
- - Et pour reprendre ce que
lele premier ministre nous disat
tatantôt.t... quelqu'un, hein,
d'd'expression anglaise, qui est
àà S Saint-Jérômeme, est-ce qu'l
esestime qu'il a le droit d'être
dédéfendu dans sa langue
mamaternelle?
- - Quand j'entends la cheffe
dudu Parti "liberal" dire...
- - Vous savez,
momonsieur le Québécois, là.....
momonsieur le président...
(r(rires)
LeLes caquistes,
c'c'est ça que vous dites.
MoMonsieur le président...
JeJe répètete les propos
dudu premier ministre!
ANANDRÉ FORTIN, leader
paparlementaire, Parti libéral
- - L'opposition a fait une errr
enen vous appelant "monsieur
lele Québécois", le premier
miministre du Québec a
ininterpellé... vous a interpelé
enen disant : "Bien oui, il est
cacaquiste." Ce qu'il dit, c'est
quque tout le monde qui n'est ps
cacaquiste n'est pas québécois.
EtEt ça, monsieur le président,
c'c'est inaceptable!
SISIMON JOLIN-BARRETTE, ministre
reresponsable Langue française,c
- - C'est odieux...
ododieux, monsieur le président!
-J-Je ne sais pas si c'est, mais
c'c'est un peu surréaliste. Made
AnAnglade s'est trompée, elle a
didit : M. les Québécois au lieu
dede dire M. le président. M.
LeLegault a dit : c'est ce qui s
QuQuébécois Voegele caquiste.
C'C'est parti, les fractures,
l'l'horizon électoral, on veut
bibien mettre la table de chacun
dede son corps.
- - Oui, c'est intéressant, ce i
sese passe aujourd'hui, parce qe
lele projet de loi 96 sur la
lalangue ne créait pas beaucoup
d'd'engouement. Quand mêmeme, à
prpropos protection de la langu,
c'c'est un des piliers du
nanationalisme de François
LeLegault. On cherche une façone
tititiller un peu cette fibre et
onon voyait aussi qu'il y avait
cecertains fractures à l l'intér
dudu  caucus au sein du
gogouvernement sur fond de valle
plplus loin pour protéger la lo,
esest-ce qu'on devrait imposer a
loloi sans oxygènene, M. Legaule
vovoulait pas et ne peut pas alr
llà. . Il a mis un terme au dép.
MaMais on a l'impression que sa
poposition de compromis a été de
didire : OK, on agrandira pas le
cécégep Dawson, mêmeme si on l't
dédéfendu, mais si c'est démonté
ququ'il y a un besoin, et son
didiscours, c'est de dire : on a
prprivilégier les francophones
avavant d'aller chez les
ananglophones. Et ça place les
lilibéraux dans une situation
imimpossible parce qu'il dépeint
DoDominique Anglade comme à l la
ttêtete du parti des anglophonet
lului il dit : moi, je protègega
mamaturité. Mais elle est dans e
sisituation où évidemment que la
cocommunauté anglophone et son
trtraditionnelle, elle n'a pas
tetellement le choix de défendre
seses positions, mais c'est très
dudur.
- - On voit la stratégie du côté
dede la CAQ, de M. Legault, c'et
clclair. Il avance comme un
bubulldozer là-d-dessus pour pre
lele pouls.
- - Mais il fait du rattrapage
auaussi, c'est-à-d-dire qu'il ee
dede pallier la faiblesse de son
prprojet de loi et en particulir
soson refus d'étendre la loi 100
auau cégep par une volte-face sr
DaDawson, il avait incluse parmi
leles projets d'infrastructures
prprioritaires dans son projet e
loloi 66, dans la nouvelle moute
dede ce mêmeme projet, il s'état
totoujours là. . Ils avaient voé
cocontre une motion, avait bloqé
unune motion qui demandait
jujustement d'annuler
l'l'agrandissement du cégep
DaDawson. Tout d'un coup, parce
ququ'il se rend compte, je pense
ququ'il est temps portafaux avec
lala majorité francophone sur la
ququestion de la loi 101. Il fat
dudu rattrapage. Sur le fond, je
susuis d'accord avec lui, dans e
nene devrait pas êtrtre agrandi,
mamais il reste que c'est de la
popolitique. Les normes, peut-êe
ququ'il fautut les changer, main
vevertu des normes existantes, e
cocollègege Dawson aurait droitn
agagrandissement en termes de
susuperficie.
- - C'est comme s'il voulait
vrvraiment cantonner Madame
AnAnglade gestion de l'aura
ananglophone, occupez-vous de, e
vavais m'occuper de tous les
frfrancophones.
- - C'est ça, ce qui est embêta,
c'c'est que M. Legault divise,
c'c'est quand mêmeme étonnant pe
ququ'il y a quelques jours, il a
lalaissé tomber son projet de
cocontribution financièrere pous
nonon-vaccinés en nous disant
ququ'il avait déjà s suffisammee
cocolèrere dans la population et
ququ'il ne voulait pas créer de
l'l'Paul-Émile polarisation. Mas
ilil se permet quand mêmeme de r
unune polarisation à b bien d'as
enendroits, comme on l'a vu avec
cece débat. C'est sûr r que pour
lului, c'est vraiment une espèce
dede voix laïcité, langue
frfrançaise, tout ce qui est
nanation québécoise, c'est le
pipilier de sa stratégie, puis a
plplace ses adversaires dans une
poposition assez compliquée pare
quque c'est comme s'il a réussià
didire : nous, à l la CAQ que ln
rereprésente la nation québécoi,
alalors qu'il y a des Québécois
ququi peuvent très s bien ne pas
êêtrtre d'accord avec ses posits
EtEt êtrtre tout de mêmeme de
vévéritables Québécois, il n'a s
lele monopole d'êtrtre Québécoi,
ququatre les Québécois ne sont s
liliés et n'excluent pas le res.
- - Année électorale, c'est cla,
DaDawson, c'est peut-êtrtre le
memeilleur exemple, vous lui
enenlevez cela du chemin et dir:
jeje vais choisir, il ne voulait
papas imposer au cégep, au moin,
j'j'agrandirais pas le plus grad
cécégep anglophone du Québec. Ms
ouoù il y a beaucoup de
frfrancophones qui vont, c'est
nonotre débat. C'est terminé